good morning Hank it's Tuesday I'm still
on vacation but don't worry I brought
35,000 sheets of paper with me and as
you can see here I've signed very nearly
120,000 sheets today I thought I'd
answer some real questions from real
nerdfighters about signing beginning
with are you literally signing 200,000
sheets of paper yes so I sign all of
these sheets and then I send them to
Pennsylvania where they are bound one by
one in two copies of my new book turtles
all the way down and because the book
obviously has to be printed somewhat in
advance of its publication on October
10th I have to finish signing by like
August 17th are you aware that your
signature is currently worth negative
four dollars on Amazon yeah I actually
think it's negative three dollars at the
moment but it's true that the signed
Edition is currently less expensive than
the unsigned one I get the same royalty
regardless and have no control over
Amazon's discounting but also Amazon
might be onto something because for like
a year after the fault in our stars came
out unsigned copies were much rarer than
signed ones how many paper cuts have you
gotten so far amazingly none yet but I
spend a lot of time worrying about it
why two hundred thousand uh at the time
it seemed like enough but not too much
why do you do this to be honest I'm not
totally sure but I do have some theories
one reason is that it's always struck me
as unfair that people who don't live
near major metropolitan areas or for
whatever reason can't go to author
events don't get signed books unless
they pay a surcharge but there are also
a lot of selfish reasons one of which is
that you know like for the last 2000
days or so I've been trying to write
this book and on most of those days I
didn't know if what I was writing would
ever make it into the book a lot of
those days I couldn't even tell if the
work I was doing was getting me closer
to a book I was proud of or further away
from it with this I know that I'm doing
something people will like and each time
I do it I get a little closer to being
done writing is not like that for me
does your hand hurt no I got some
incredibly effective physical therapy
when I was doing this for The Fault in
Our Stars because I have owner nerve
entrapment and since then I've been able
to just sign all day why don't you hire
someone to make a machine that perfectly
mimics your signature you know there are
some jobs that robots just can't do and
one of them is monotonous ly creating
the same scratch on a page two hundred
thousand times how consistent is your
signature tend to be so I think it
varies wildly but Sarah thinks I just
spend way too much time looking at my
signature I've grabbed three here that I
think are very different to give you a
sense of the variation how many papers
can you sign in an hour
it takes about two hours to do a
thousand so in total this project is
going to take around 400 hours would you
please put that pen to work on another
book instead of a zillion fairly
anonymous tokens no see the problem is
the pen does not want to work on another
book what kind of pen are you using I
use sharpies and lots of them I'm in
something of a blue period by the way
are you sponsored by Sharpie no I wish
I'm ready to sell out for some of that
sweet sweet Sharpie money but no I buy
my sharpies how do you decide what
colors to sign in
well you're deciding to cover break down
at the last hundred thousand thanks to
your votes do you ever write or draw
random things in some of the books along
with your signature yes for reasons that
will become obvious to readers of the
book I sometimes make a spiral what good
media have you been enjoying while
signing I'm mostly listening to podcasts
including all of these but I also listen
to Pride and Prejudice on audiobook and
it is still great
what's your rhythm pull place sign pass
I guess my rhythm looks approximately
like this and then once that done pile
gets big enough I stack them and start
again can you draw Turtles all the way
down on mine no but I did draw
signatures all the way down on this one
what are some interesting thoughts
you've had during this process I would
actually say the chief pleasure of it is
that I don't have very many thoughts at
all when you first started signing the
books did you think it was fun I
honestly still think it's fun where can
i buy the book somebody knows how to
ensure their question gets answered the
signed edition has its own ISBN there
are links in the doobly-doo below but
also pretty much wherever books are sold
and lastly can I hang codfish some Hank
I'll be putting this box in the mail
shortly I'll see you on Friday